if all the knowledge
and this episode today is brought to you
by casper mattresses buddy I'm just
gonna say are you still sleeping on your
guest mattress horse uh I just got off
the road and so been traveling a lot
sleeping on hotel mattresses and when I
come home to this mattress it is great I
i love this sponsor because every night
I sleep in my own bed I'd like I'm so
grateful these guys like podcasting yeah
because it is is is and not did it gets
softer now you've been on it from did
they tell you that in the information
when you get to like give your body
sometimes a couple weeks but you didn't
necessarily believe it no I well I don't
believe anybody yeah I don't believe you
yeah you're talking but you needed proof
I need a proof I need to prove that you
are who you say I don't know that that
house next to this garage is yours oh
that's why I never let you go in it okay
now i need a deed I need to see a deed
with your game button um but yeah so the
Casper mattress it is and I get such
great sleep from it I cannot say this
enough and it was it was a hundred days
to try it out like I don't know of any
other mattress company that gives you a
hundred days to try it out and if you
don't like it just send it back to them
cuz at first I got to be honest when
they came to us I was like sweet they
shipped mattresses in the mail like
right what is this and it came in like a
tube or something good came as it comes
in a box and you cut it open and then it
kind of slowly unfolds right and then
you graph like arrest exactly i'm like
well but this is this is my cast away
yeah so uh yeah I make became friends
with a volleyball and then and then I
slept on this mattress but now I cannot
say enough it is risk-free it my
mattress was like you know the queen
size is 850 I believe or something in
that neighbor they're very reasonably
priced and it's a it's a great night
sleep like if you're in the in the
market for a mattress and you don't want
my last mattress cost me 2 grand the
right for this one hmm and was nice it
was worth it but that's a lot of money
yes and this one I cannot say enough
about Casper so well
you know one of the things we love too
is when a sponsor actually gives the
fans of the podcast a discount so make
sure you go to Casper calm / comedy film
nerds use the promo code comedy film
nerds and you will get fifty dollars off
which is considering like a twin
mattress is 500 bucks and then the King
their biggest mattress is 950 right
let's rocket down to 90 ukitaka nine
kids get the big thing so you know that
that's a pretty solid deal they got the
Sea King the California came in
California king and they've all regular
King to get the regular King all
different kinds of Royals yeah got a
full house if you buy all their
mattresses um yeah and it's risk free
man and if you don't like it send it
back and the shipping is free so there's
no there's no roof there's no risk so go
for it you guys and it's a cool way to
to support the site if you're in the men
in the market for mattress you're
helping us and you're and you're getting
a great product so Casper CA sper calm /
comedy film nerds and use the promo code
comedy film nerds 50 beans off 50 bangs
off sleep my children they well welcome
to a comedy film nerd special special
themed episode this is a special themed
episode very special or is subtitled the
vacation episode because one of us or
both of us is out of town and you have
recorded this at a pre at a date yeah
four years ago four years ago it's
really good it's a time travel episode
um so we're gonna get into a classic
classic films mainly classic comedy
movies but let's introduce our guest yes
first time on the program first time and
I open for this gentleman many years ago
in Philadelphia when they used to have a
funny bone there Wow a hundred years ago
I know he doesn't remember you yes of
course not I don't does I don't remember
me from that time it'd be awful if he
did yeah because it's up yeah you
Reverend oh I remember you
that [ __ ] a brother a toaster ons
data and it's stupid out yeah and then
he just storms out of the garage yeah
but how dare you why are you still in
good ladies and gentlemen Gilbert
Godfrey yeah i'm i'm hoping to forget
you right after I yeah we hope most of
our guests yet yeah but that's how we
get repeat guests yeah yeah we just want
to either be horrible or kind of just
not memory I have no recollection in
that episode am I must have had a good
time yeah my drive through sherman oaks
i think of movies yeah i know why that's
weird i'm just gonna keep driving uh so
gilbert you do you have a podcast till
ow you know about Ida I'm one of the
four guys downloaded yeah we were guests
on it oh yes yes you are so good on that
one we promised your show yes you do
every week you're done a bang-up job I
wish I have you jumped in I was just
about to tell you how terrific both of
you are and now I couldn't do it without
you yeah Gilbert Gottfried's amazing
colossal podcast it's cold and you can
hear it on Gilbert Gottfried dot-com now
what's the other information uh oh
there's a Facebook Gilbert Gilbert
Gottfried's amazing colossal podcast and
my twitter is at real Gilbert what's
with the one hand Sean Merrick whoo-hoo
you brought him over here said anything
yes what was the other thing I left out
I delivered style network TV I can't run
see i wish i wish the information was
given to some announcer that could just
say it and I'll go oh here he is doing
that dumb earn plug and I don't have to
be the one like he's the bad guy
like a good cop bad oh yes yes hey I
know you're an all right kid why don't
you talk to me my partner's a little
crazy straw you better listen you better
listen I I'm gonna be here at this stage
I'm gonna be here at this day and itunes
com yeah sideshow network talk to you
punks yeah I'm gonna put a hurtin on
yeah yeah you better do what he says
it's mad I don't know if he's gonna ask
me to leave the room than I I don't know
what's gonna happen I've been dealing
with you young punks my whole life the
time you open for me in Philly yeah but
on my podcast haha well on my on his
podcast that's the announcer who's bad
no I I i specialized I like to like
focus on old Hollywood so I've had on I
just interviewed Lee Meriwether oh wow
Catwoman and and Julie Newmar who was
cat well Kelso Catwoman and and adam
west batman of course and and roger
corman you had Roger yeah sure yeah what
was that like at that was great because
you know he's the king of guy d movies
yeah but any this book is like how i
made what like a hundred movies in
Hollywood out losing a dime about that
yeah and and he told us one movie he
made was he was gonna go out and with
some friends and play tennis and then he
got up that morning and it was raining
so he decided to make a movie instead
yes and he found out a Boris Karloff
owed him like two days work from a
previous movie so he called up Boris
Karloff and this totally unknown Jack
Nicholson
and they were in this movie called a
terror and to this day because it rained
yes yes yeah and to this state nobody
knows the plot of the movie they just
know there was a castle left over at
some studio from a previous Phil I saw
this movie I get this movie is on snag
like insane yeah it makes no sense yeah
I night I just ran into at some event da
dick miller mmm who was in you're one of
those guys in everyone he did a thousand
gorman films and he said to me that
that's absolutely true uh they had Boris
Karloff and they said okay um walk down
this hallway now look in that door yeah
now look on that whole way and turn
around and like the castle had like a
lever on the bottom where the dungeon
was and that would just flood it from
the ocean yes yes like why would you
build a lever in the bottom of your
castle to flood it I I always I always
loved that in the old movies they used
to have the lever that you blew up the
cast right yeah you know they had that
in the black cat son of Frankenstein no
it's a lever that blows up the cat well
why did you wouldn't that be a stupid
thing well now on IMDb direct it says
directors Roger Corman and then it says
Francis Ford Coppola and then there's
three other people that are uncredited
Oh Francis Ford Coppola uncredited Monty
hellmann's uncredited and jack hill and
Jack Nicholson all th took eighth day
you know yeah you had to direct their
own scenes yeah just like like one was
taking a nap yeah any other would direct
now did Roger crim did you guys talk
about Little Shop of Horrors ah yeah we
talked about that we talked about a few
things that people don't realize that
that there is an original movie that's
not a musical I never ours and well you
got you a better your Nicholson decision
yeah yeah as the patient crazy demands
hilarious in that movie as that you know
the the masochistic Dental patient yes
1960 was yeah it was like oh no no no
became oh yeah it's great now you're
Miller's in that movie is oh yes and
there's a scene in the terror where Dick
Miller has to do one of those scenes
that's awful in every movie where they
have to explain basically to the
audience those are always clumsy see the
expositions yes yeah why where they act
like they're talking to the other person
and the scene but it's really for the
audience to take notes and and he he
does hot or in this case maybe for the
director yes he explains and when he
explains what it is you're more confused
when you an anti exposition system oh
and it well it's just like I remember I
was watching this movie ah that where
Kevin Spacey was Bobby Darin I I forget
what it was it was busy with Bobby do
yeah yeah like something that you have
usual suspects cuz or so say say
baradaran see I think about the sea or
on the sea oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I know
what you're talking about yes beyond the
sea yeah yeah question there's late
Bobby Darin's 2004 he's so he's a
regular life Kevin Spacey yeah and he's
a real-life singer bobby darin and the
guy playing his managers John Goodman
and John Goodman has a scene that you
have to feel bad for him because he a
spacey as Bobby Darin says my career is
nothing it's never gone anywhere
and and and John Goodman has to
dramatically go what are you kidding
Bobby for three years straight in 1962
you are the top performer in Vegas
you've already been nominated for an
Academy Award you've got seven gold
albums and it's like it's like II expect
him to look at the screen you go you
taking all this down so now we also had
a job oh I'm Weird Al Yankovic gah Bob
Saget mmm so what are some of your
favorite like old Hollywood stories or
or like or comedy movies like what you
love about old Hollywood comedy movies
ah god I don't know there there's some
that I I I remember growing up they had
all the old movies on TV which probably
worn even had hold when I listen air
first-run syndication I mean like like
it's so weird when you talk to someone
and they go oh yeah I really love those
old movies like Titanic it's like you
tell someone like I used to watch Three
Stooges on TV I'm sure and I'm like well
what what are you talking about you know
they have no idea cuz if they don't play
on TV where you have to find him on DVD
or online and but they're just not
available the way they used to be yeah I
used to watch The Three Stooges every
day in New York we had captain a captain
oat officer Joe Bolton and he was like
the friendly cop who would swingers
night stick around and presented three
stooges that's great Joe like stay in
school yes and smack your buddy in the
face yeah and you know and it took the
studio a long time to release all those
shorts like in chronological order like
it used to be like you could get like a
couple
together now you can get the whole set
and if you actually watch them in order
from when they were made like I have the
said I haven't watched amalia but
they're fantastic in fact they were so
satirical even like I mean obviously
their slapstick but like one of the
early ones they were talking about going
to Hollywood because they were
vaudeville performers they're on a train
there like hobos and the bars going like
well yeah well Hollywood's run by morons
what's three more gonna make a
difference you know they already biting
the hand that fed them and it was uh
it's interesting because you don't see
that kind of program anymore no one
makes 15 20 minute elements like to play
before feature films anymore that's a
bygone era and they did too ah that mock
hitler yeah before anybody yup dated uh
one was uh those nuts of those Nazi
spies and the other was I'll never hile
again yeah and mo played a great Hitler
he looked like yeah that was it was so
funny about just added a mustache that
was it so it was probably meaner yeah
yeah I'm sure that joke was made on yeah
sure majan yeah yeah actly so now let's
talk about some classic comedy films
like your big Marx Brothers yes as am i
and what are some of your favorite Marx
Brothers movies well it's funny it it's
like they fit another thing when they do
like box sets now of the Marx Brothers
they'll have like go waste the big store
love happy and it's like so if you older
with me those yeah those are the those
are the ones the last couple of runs
they made the forties and so now if
someone got those box I'd say we go well
what's so funny about the mantra
because there was no duck soup yeah yeah
duck soup well duck soup was their best
their absolute craziest I I agree with
that I thought duck soup was I mean I've
watched that over and over and it was
it's so funny and the jokes are they
still make you laugh it's funny like I
was watching actually last night on PBS
they were doing Dick Cavett talking
about the end of the Vietnam War and all
of these oh yeah these big interviews
that he had on there and they had
Groucho Marx whose at that point in his
60s or something like that on Dick
Cavett and he was clearly like I'm you
know I'm not happy with what's going on
with this war and I don't like it but
then wood stills the way he would say
things he would he was getting laughs
yeah like and not in Hawaii he was like
I just done you know I can't have an
impression but you just be like severe
now which I don't understand why we save
these troops to Vietnam you ask that
you're like wow here's this guy very
seasoned then he would just go home i
can let me throw like a tet offensive
joke or something and you're just like
this is amazing we went to Vietnam cuz
Chico needed the money what's she gonna
need the money he were sure came he
never had anyone well that's the thing i
think what happens in when I some people
go out you know I don't I like black and
white I don't get it or the comedies too
broad sometimes people say that I go
you're watching it from a distance
you've got to watch these movie and
watch it with all temporary glass no no
you've got to watch it and get in watch
it close there's these subtle jokes
there's these political statements that
they're making better so like well first
you have to kind of know what's going on
historically at that era yeah but there
it's it's it's uh you can see the
building blocks of which comedies that
came after
you know basically the if they influence
those movies you know you wouldn't have
the modern comedies without these so
you're kind of going back to the
beginning like I remember with duck soup
like you're saying Graham is uh they
were satirizing not only like war movies
but also big grin musical oh yeah and it
was an art form back then that we don't
really have now because I don't know
about attention spans like you basically
have a five to ten-minute plot yeah what
they make it work oh yeah I literally
make it work because it's so filled with
jokes and gags and all this is going on
idea that so much of it is just so
nonsensical yes like he's like
prosecuting Chico in the big trial yeah
and then all of a sudden he turns in its
defend him just because it gets a life
yeah yeah and you know it's funny when
you say that about how they lead to
later things um one guy was writing
about the x-files and he said you know
the x-files is great and it's so much
better than old ridiculous crap like
twilight zone oh my yeah that's the
dumbest thing ever and and in this faith
was that a 19 year old writer oh yeah
yeah and in his favor I'm the producer
of x-files said uh you know I appreciate
the compliment but they wouldn't be an
x-files if it wasn't for the exactly so
yeah when people miss that they just
don't understand like you know whatever
I've heard you go you know listen to
like Bill Haley and I like it's such
simple rock and I go yeah but that's
that's what we're everyone is standing
on those shoulders those are building a
lot of any of this and if you look like
like duck soup like I'm gonna just read
for anyone who's never seen it this is
this is the the description on IMDb so
Rufus T Firefly is named president /
dictator of bankrupt fredonia and
declares war on neighboring sylvania
over the love of wealthy mrs. Teasdale
if that's not talking about uh corporate
governments oh yeah
that would listen to that much passion
they named uh the neighboring country
they invade after a popular television
yes so there was making TVs at the time
and the TVR was just starting to happen
and it's called bankrupt fredonia he's a
slash dictator yeah I mean they're
getting into and you gotta understand
the 30s uh you know after the depression
there's a lot of people that were not
happy with how this government handled
it that's when like socialism and people
were were wanting to be know whatever
you think of communism but the people
back then believed communism in its
purest form actually on paper it doesn't
sound like a bad plan you know what I
mean like everybody gets a job everybody
eats and so they're really in this and
again in the mosser ilysm like sucks
haha what kind of means it means
communal yeah it means come that's what
it comes from it's never been practiced
correctly just use it as yeah hey I'm
gonna gain all the power no no this is
what you wanted yeah this is what you
wanted but I mean so if you understand
when these movies were being made and
yes it was escapism from the depression
but they were still in the silliest way
poking so much like social commentary
and political commentary that it's like
wow I mean what they're saying is 0
governments are all the corporate and
corrupt and they invade for money and
why does that sound familiar today is
the member reading like Roger Ebert said
that his father was a big Marx Brothers
fan and would take him to Marx Brothers
movies and whenever they'd say a line on
screen he would kind of turn to him the
father would look at him with this glow
in his eyes like you see what they just
did you see what they got away with you
know like it was sneaky one it would and
and that's what they forget you know
it's like back then that was really they
were really edgy yeah it was at what yet
also to you got it
like you say why it was so it doesn't
seem that edgy to us now because you can
swear and say whatever but the language
and the two I mean you were so
scrutinized anything every frame every
word like they could shut you down so
you you had to walk such a tight rope to
get any of these things in there and the
fact that they did which is why Robert
Roger Ebert's dad was doing that yeah
saying the in you gotta if you it so
when I I say this if you go into
watching these movies with that
knowledge and that knowledge of the
history of one they came out it suddenly
makes them amazing like it really it
really ripe you know go go into watching
these movies with the right perspective
the other thing is they're shorter you
know they're all janitor it's a smaller
time investment now what's another Marx
Brothers movies that you movie that you
really liked before the forties movies
like in the 30s in their heyday oh well
the others my my second favor would be
horsefeathers okay where he's the the
Dean of the school and yeah yeah that's
another really good one and I think he's
wack staffed there yeah Quincy Adams
Wagstaff yes president lastly University
hires bumblers ravelli and pinky to help
his school when the big football game
against rival Darwin University like now
they're just the other just spoofing of
big-time college athletics oh yeah I'm
in the 30s college football was that and
boxing were the two biggest sports in
this country and they were making big
money and that's like there was
corruption happening back then and we
think you know we always look back it's
funny we look at today's college
football it's his billion-dollar
industry and it's so corrupt and we look
back that as the golden era there was
corruption back then oh yeah well in in
in horsefeathers Chico was running a
speakeasy yeah and they've got that long
scene where he doesn't allow Groucho in
uh cuz it's he has to say swordfish
that's the wholeness
and this is old reference there ah he
says well i'll give you the i'll give
you a hint it's the name of a fish and
and he goes uh oh no chico says well
it's the name of a fish and grouchy goes
is it haddock and he goes hey that's so
funny I got a haddock too and he goes
what do you take for a headache and he
goes well sometimes they take aspirin
sometimes I take a calomel and you know
so obviously calomel was some kind of
headache medication right or this like
also in there this where they say the
Dean is waiting in the hallway he's
waxing Roth and grouchy goes well tell
her all to wax the Dean for a while and
but waxing Roth I guess was a way of
saying you're getting upset waxing Roth
there's definitely slang and stuff that
we don't have any yeah yeah that they
that they use but but but horsefeathers
definitely made me laugh out loud and
you also have to with the Marx Brothers
is they were they were very specific
characters no matter what movie they
were in it was literally never like oh
well you're playing this your they were
always a character playing a character
again every movie and then see now I
always thought when night night at the
opera that was their biggest hit I don't
Lucille Ball with it too right oh yeah
and but Night at the Opera that's Irving
Spielberg I didn't a Spielberg irving
thalbro took over them and there are a
duck soup i think is what lost in their
contract with paramount cuz it no one
saw it no one liked it back then Wow and
and then names one of their best movies
yes it's yeah and and it's like Irving
feldburg made put them in Night at the
Opera which was a major hit and I think
when i watch Night at the Opera that
looks like the beginning of the end to
them cuz they look like they had a leash
on them gosh and they were doing things
for a reason they were helping out the
romantic couple one and so that was
always they weren't sort of creating
anarchy that's yeah the best things is
in those other movies we're talking
about there they were just they were
kind of ruining every oh yeah that was
their whole thing is they would take
these established iconic parts of the
society and ruin them and so when
they're playing along it's like wall and
that doesn't work as well when you're
supporting characters right you have yet
gonna be at that in the driver's seat so
figured that comedians used to be
supporting characters in their own
movies right right like the romantic
leads were the leads and they were just
these wacky guys who would pop up oh
yeah let me support the the guy in the
girl was right met and fell in love yes
let me ask you this when like how did
watching these movies or when did
influence you to be like I want to be a
comedian I want to start doing this yeah
God um um I don't know i watch all these
old movies and old TV shows and like
like those variety shows and movies
that's like the you know got me in that
mindset where my podcast is it's like
old old Hollywood I'm just fascinated by
it and I don't know I started to imitate
people I saw in movies and stuff like
that I just eventually I when I first
when I first used to perform like at
open mic nights I was doing mainly
imitations of who like Boris Karloff and
Humphrey bogan back then my act was
dated how it's like
you started with an outdated AG that's
awesome I was on stage at 15 doing stuff
that rich little I would be ashamed of
and how come you don't see
Impressionists anymore I know to me it's
like the only time somebody does an
impression like when we had any night we
had kevin Pollak on right well here we
we always demand does made him do our ad
read as Christopher Walken but no it's
funny it like the only we had one right
now we would have you do it as Boris
Karloff and and I and and then it would
have to be where I turn around with my
back to the audience mish my hair lift
my collar up and an ankle it might go
something like this I remember uh god I
remember when I saw you on TV do your
impression of dice dice was at his
zenith and then you just did you think
you're making him again the first two
minutes you just do the thing with your
arms God what I yah yah i was talking
finish Bravo boo and then I remember
doing you did David Brenner a long time
boom boom boom boom room chili you know
I remember years ago seeing an
impressionist just like one of the clubs
and they always had like some premise to
hold voices like like oh this is the
Hollywood classroom
or the Hollywood press conference yeah
would it be weird if Arnold
Schwarzenegger was your dentist like
opens your mouth guys like some horrible
oh and in this this guy was doing a
thing where his car breaks down on the
highway and so each impression he'd
introduced by going why there's Jack
Nicholson maybe he'll help Oh horrible
there's Kirk Douglas maybe he'll help
and Margot do you know how to change a
tire oh that's great so I no matter who
finally changed the tire is it Jim
Nabors to go oh my god Carol Channing
yeah maybe showed up five plugs are a
girl's best friend thanks Carol Wow no
one's doing a brush like that but now
I'll see like a comic will have any time
I comic doesn't obscure impression of
somebody they just like busts out like a
Richard Dreyfuss impression or something
that I'll i absolutely love that oh yeah
cuz it just comes out of nowhere have to
be from Jaws yeah and I mean there are
still people who have an earful voices
like and they'll be on comedy shows like
Saturday Night Live and stuff but the
whole premise of going it might have
imagined it Al Pacino worked at
McDonald's I think it would go a little
something oh hi and I like to love the
ones that can't do the actor so they'll
do a character that the actor played yo
and they'll say like imagine if your
dentist was Dustin Hoffman the way he
was in Rain Man
it's also that thing we would always say
to you knew was a shitty impression when
they would have to say who they were and
the introduction because they don't just
be like um Ron Reagan here oh yeah cuz
if you just went hey how you doing know
what I go yeah going ron rojo general
white yeah it's the guy with all the
sirens but know what let's move on to I
want to talk about Abbott and Costello
oh yes because I when I was printing out
the list I forgot how many movies they
act I did they were breaking up what to
a year it was it was crazy and I'm
looking at him too and not only are they
in all these different situations but
eventually they did like they did a
Marvel Universe crossover kind of thing
with the Keystone Cops oh yes yes and
and all of the universal monsters and
all of a sudden I will every single
universe what there was an avin Costello
movie one of my all-time favorite
comedies abbott and costello meet
frankenstein yes such a great one the
thing that's the thing i love it not
just Frankenstein to yeah a Dracula yeah
man they're all in that movie and Lugosi
is back in Dracula and like Hollywood
had given up they were using John
Carradine as Dracula and everyone else
but Lugosi and when Lugosi appear says
Dracul you go oh this is what was
missing from all those other dragon yeah
well no the thing that was cool about
that was they they kept it just scary
enough yes that that it actually
enhanced the jokes because it was it
wasn't just like when it was like oh no
these are these actual guys who were
terrifying on the big screen whatever 10
15 20 years ago and now so they're still
bringing their their skill as horror
black and white horror film actors which
was an amazing skill that they possess
yes and then so that it made the jokes
like land to me even harder because you
were kind of like oh [ __ ] yeah you were
a little scary and and the
movie was respectful of the monsters yes
they didn't make them like stupid know
what I think too I I you know I this is
something it'd be great to have on your
podcast to know but I always got the
feeling like they went oh we love Bela
Lugosi we love Boris Karloff so like how
can you know I'm sure they were just
respectful on the set and they're like
we're gonna be the idiots guys you have
to do what you do your yeah fun your
awesome thing and let us be the morons
in an lon chaney jr. was back as the
Wolfman yeah it was an all-star monster
cast in the in the app and Costello film
and that was one of the most famous ones
too and they brought on they started
that whole meet and go to and then knows
each one got worse than they got bad
when when they did meet the mummy well
literally you're making it and i'm
looking at i'm looking at 1941 they
released four films oh wow four films it
was a buck privates in the Navy hold
that Ghost and keep them flying no one
makes four movies in a year they used to
churn out movie yes they had that whole
thing where like they could if they
wanted to make it in a day they make it
in right yeah you're under contract
we're paying you whether you're making a
movie today you're not so guess what
you're gonna be making all yes and a lot
of times too ah they would have an actor
doing three movies at once yeah well
you'd have to run across the set oh yeah
you'd be like you're doing a musical in
the morning then you're chasing a guy
and then the afternoon your tap your
eyes exactly you're on a cruise ship now
I remember watching a bike and Stella
was a kid to thinking that like you know
Costello was the funny one and Abbas
like why he's so boring why would I ever
why is he even in this and then as you
get older and start to appreciate you
realize you Costello would never be as
funny without the straight man people
that drives me nuts when i'll hear
people and it's the same thing like
writers who don't know what they're
talking about right and it's like when
you're a real Abbott and Costello fan
the one you're laughing at the most is
Abbot right cuz he's great in those when
you're a kid you love mo the most then
when you get older you like Larry yeah
oh yes he's the everyman yes imagine if
Larry was your dead yes Michael a little
something like this imagine if Larry was
your dentist but he talked like Al
Pacino in Scarface say hello to my
little friends that's the drill sound
you know from the dentist get a free
download from audible he's doing our
address yeah [ __ ] and and um well like
abid made everything so matter of fact
that made it so great like like the
who's on first right it's like what's so
funny about it when you watch it because
Abbott is so good in in your mind you're
going what WI's Costello so stupid that
he doesn't know who's on first what's on
second I know our real names right yeah
and and there were these assigns that
Abbott would have liked I one part that
cracks me up on who's on first is you
know castello says you know I'm a pretty
good catcher myself and I because so
they tell me yeah it's just so funny
he's got so many of those that if you're
not paying attention which a lot of
times he says them while most people are
probably laughing at at at Lou yeah
there lad Costello just landed
everyone's laughing and that tells a
little less Allah tell me like he's a
bunch of those are like oh he just kind
of slammed her or equal to whatever
jokey's make and in abbott and costello
meet frankenstein is a one-pot Costello
is trying to tell him that the monsters
are there near and he's waving his arms
in the air like Frankenstein and Dracula
and doing that like chicken and and he's
waving know doing the arm the
Frankenstein arms outstretched and
Dracula hypnotizing someone and an
Abbott at one point just goes okay okay
put your hand side enough of the silly
business kid like and you know we're far
enough removed from these movies to that
like if I read the titles it sounds like
we're doing a bit oh yeah sure I where
they are like lost in Alaska ivan
costello meet captain kidd abbott and
costello go tomorrow yeah adventist a
low meet dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde these
are actual movies and this is where a
lot of the you know kind of like the
comedy premises came from oh yeah you
would see the three stooges in a haunted
house and Old West and this is where
this is the the building blocks of all
of those drugs where you take comedians
and put them in all these different
situations or different planets orange
at times yes you know the time periods
yeah there's got Jack and the Beanstalk
you've got Evan costello meet captain
kidd i just like oh damn is right on
cowboy in the Navy buck privates on
their TV show where the landlord would
say boys boys and they were both in
their 60 yeah both like on ceridian hold
but there's even there there's one part
Costello is doing all the funny business
and they have habit just sitting in a
chair with a cup of coffee there and
Costello's do is in the forefront doing
everything and Ave it's just they're so
Abbott like like taps both his hands on
the table and goes nice hot cup of
coffee oh and do you this this I love I
talked about this on my podcast like
every other episode um did you you must
have seen the TV movie button Lou
with aa buddy hackett as Lou Costello
and Harvey Korman oh my gosh is a long
time ago Hey Hey look like two guys who
had never seen and I've been in custody
and but my favorite thing when i try to
do a Three Stooges movie same thing oh
oh god yes it was n came out 1978 button
low it was there was there's a death
scene there with Buddy Hackett as Lou
Costello and Artie Johnson from life and
plays Eddie Sherman the manager and and
he said he sneaks in like a cup with
like from a candy store like and he goes
you know what I got you here Lou and he
goes over vaulted and he goes yeah and
he he he holds on to it very weakly
Buddy Hackett is Lou Costello takes one
sip and goes you know hey I had a lot of
glory voltage in my gay but get one the
best and then he falls down dead so a
strawberry malted kill artists his
manager killed it
only needed was for the doctors to run
and go you know he's allergic to
strawberries you've killed a great comic
genius oh boy Harvey Korman Buddy
Hackett um what else we got here I'd
like Jerry Lewis ice the Nutty Professor
that is a great and there's another one
once you really watch it and appreciate
it you're really laughing the most when
he's buddy love absolutely yeah Oh mr.
barroom brawler don't bother me yeah
it's it's really and you see kind of
like especially thing as we we know more
about jury list I'm like oh that's Jerry
Liu yeah that's yes him and it's like
and when he says now repeat after me
I'll I'll pay I'll pay attention so a
and this is out this a movie that came
out what year was a naughty professor
like 64 festivals and this was of course
in Jerry Lewis's heyday with ya member
63 yeah yeah it was uh it was it was
really again it was a basically a dr.
Jekyll miss ya comedy but it was really
funny oh yeah and I just remember like
you know seeing as a kid too and gun is
that is that the same guy oh yeah is he
yeah so committed to both characters and
they were so different uh it was it's
just a really good classic synthetic
Jerry Lewis's is a really good actor the
thing about the Nutty Professor that
makes sense as he's as I said is what we
know historically of the interviews
about Dean and Jerry Dean Martin
everyone thought all he's the guy with
the chicks he was the guy going back to
his room early getting sleep Jerry Lewis
was the guy yeah
partying with this with the showgirls
and all that stuff so it made sense like
it makes his is is his character in The
Nutty Professor even more like oh that's
he was up just a Playboy you know it was
like tagging them two at a time or
whatever and I heard you I didn't need a
magic formula yeah when when when i
whenever I've asked people who've worked
with lewis uh what he's like I've heard
that term well he's like a Jekyll and
Hyde cuz they say one minute he's like
really funny and a great guy and then he
could turn on yet real yeah Wow have you
had him on the podcast yet I know no I'd
love to have on the podcast well it's
it's kind of too late when you think
about that John are you making notes I
talked to Jerry Lewis's publicist let me
let me take it so of my natural mango
essence drink nothing but the best here
in the garage that's like cut natural
latex nature's own styrofoam nature
styrofoam is really it is delicious
gorgeous yes especially this time of
year all fresh off the fine get the
low-hanging styrofoam it is ready to go
oh but no I want to talk about you said
bring of Jerry Lewis the king of comedy
which I know is not a comedy yeah but it
shows you I think to me that's probably
the most it feels like at least the most
accurate insight into who Jerry Liu oh
yes yes you know of that's who he was
like that big of a guy I mean but that's
an amazing that film you know like
historically people don't talk it's not
on a short list of yeah classic amazing
films where I think it should be because
you've got you've got a young Sandra
Bernhard who plays of Looney tune
[ __ ] to the T and you know a lot of
it is made you know a lot of the movie
was made about Robert De Niro of course
he plays a you know a good performance
but it's you gotta watch that
for Jerry Lewis oh yeah because he's so
like kind of cold kind of ha yeah that's
kind of in you're just like wow that's
probably the Jerry Lewis you've had
people tell you that that Jacqueline ha
oh yeah and and you know what uh what's
odd oh I well I originally had asked
Johnny Carson to play that part and he
didn't want to so they got Jerry Lewis
who used to you know sub would be a
substitute on The Tonight Show it works
with Jerry Lewis oh yeah it definitely
works with him and and it is fascinating
to look at him in there I think it went
to when you talk about a new one every
one talks about Scorsese films they
always forget this one oh yeah because
they are I'm granted it's because
Scorsese has this amazing body of
classic films but you're just I'm always
like the King of Comedy the king of
comedy is is is probably his most
underrated movie yeah and it is it is so
Jerry Lewis and and it's what what else
I think what king of comic let's not
forget to where else are you gonna find
Robert De Niro playing a comedian oh
yeah like a korean won trivia comic yeah
and um in will King of Comedy I think
one one of the problems people have with
it there's something very frustrating
about it like the audience is frustrated
the whole characters and everything it's
like and the way it ends you going ooh
yeah like I know I think that's part of
it too and I know at the time people
were like oh we thought it was gonna be
Jerry Lewis being wack oh yeah yeah yeah
that's like no I think it's one of those
I'm sure it was marketed wrong oh yeah I
know it was I remember as a kid going
what is this so wait it's it's robert de
niro is gonna be funny that's going on
like I couldn't quite figure it out so
they and they marketed it as the king of
cool oh yeah like Oh in this one part
and King of Comedy that Jerry Lewis told
them about and they put it in a movie
where somebody is on the paper there's a
woman
the pay phone and she goes a a Jerry
Jerry talk to you know say hello to my
brother my brother's on that he goes on
him in a hurry and she goes you should
die of cancer and he said that happened
to him in real life yeah I don't doubt
that I hope that yeah well I mean
there's also uh there's also a funny
thing if you everyone listen to it
there's a you ever listen to those
golden throats of those cds that came on
yes yes Anthony Quinn yet William
Shatner people Wiggin out there's a
great one of a guy who's drunk calling
and he's like what are they the Golden
throats is they got you know it's like
all of these celebrities and major
athletes either losing their [ __ ] like
it's it's all those a Tommy Lasorda
yelling hit the press and oh well its
got William Shatner you know if I want
to say sabotage I'll say sabotage it's
all and there's the classic the most
famous one is Orson Welles doing a
voiceover for some commercial for some
radio commercial and and he owe ya one
point he goes uh I said they say you
know in the death of your ignorance yes
what do you want yeah yeah that got
animated Warner Brothers enemy as a
pinky memory so yeah he's the big
brained mouth and they did it word for
word and they had the it's like these
two English commercial guys are telling
him and they say can you emphasize in in
in July and he goes you tell me how to
emphasize in in in July and I'll go down
on ya oh well that's a go throes of
these cds now you remember just get them
all on you two or whatever but they had
a million of those oh yeah they had they
have buddy rich loot oh yeah who's going
[ __ ] nuts in his uh untended tour bus
with his band which is then there's a
and that song sabotage by the beastie
boys he goes I'm like Buddy Rich when I
I off the handle like he's aiming at his
band there's another great one will
robert mitchum member in the 80s he did
those beef it's what's for dinner so yes
so he's like beef it's what's for dinner
and you hear some yum goong guy in the
booth go that's great Bob can we just
try to do this and this and this and he
just goes you'll suck my what yeah I
know the kid goes that last take was
great i mentioned thank you so much Oh
in this one with Paul Anka where he's
yelling at his band and he keeps going
and that's just the [ __ ] way it is
the one that is glut this is great Jerry
Lewis this drunk guy is calling he gets
ahold of Jerry Lewis's office or
something and he's like look I'm friends
with Jerry and Jerry Lewis is on the
phone guy doesn't know it's Jerry Lewis
and he's got the wrong disease do he's
got he's saying MS yeah yeah and Jerry
Lewis just [ __ ] with this guy oh yeah
that is great brilliant the guys like
Laura I want to come on the show ok you
want to go get some snow no I'm on the
show it just keeps doing that and it's
like something like well what is your
name you know Irving so your name's mr.
vane no an earthy the guys drug can you
spell it I had a ghost I am mr. ving the
guys like I know Jake is it it's
actually Louis at his classic funniest
it is so brilliant the fact that he had
the wherewithal cuz I gotta record this
and he's just you know a guy at that
level has had so many people wanting
stuff free tickets and I guess this guy
is I'm friends with the many things
yelling at somebody s and it's that you
know sure Jerry Lewis wanted to go I've
never yeah you I don't know who you are
the strength of luggage [ __ ] prohee
yeah he's like he's asking for his
number to spell the name he has him
respect n time
every time and and and Louis he's so
just like okay yes sir yeah so he's so
respectful like a respectful secretary
assistant and just can't get this simple
process I foetus you want to run
thursday yeah okay so sunday we've got
you down for son oh and there's also uh
Casey Kasem oh yeah the Casey Kay's it
was a great so brilliant he's like you
know he's talking about like like oh and
this is for a little Susie whose dog
puffy died recently and then he stops
and he goes so I gotta follow this with
a song about a little girls [ __ ] dog
dying there's so but I I had that I had
a copy that like when I first came out
in the 90s I would listen to it there
was the one there was the former manager
of the Chicago Cubs in the 80s namely
Elia and this was back when the Cubs
didn't have lights yeah all of the games
were day games and this is the early 80s
and the cubs were awful and he goes on
this tirade and he's like eighty five
percent of the populations work and the
other fifteen percent come down here in
boom boy team hahaha that's a playground
for the [ __ ] so there's this like
and there was a commercial but this
one's on camera also Orson Welles and he
obviously he's bombed out of his skull
and he has to say you know ah the French
she would pick closure gala wats
appointment wonder like with Orson
Welles like what why are you doing
commercial yeah why bother yeah and end
but buddy in the commercial he's so
drunk he's gone you know you expect him
to go you know are the French but in
says oh wow the French I'll tell you
guys find that it listen to that um
having trouble directing himself watch
uh well let's talk about but when you
have time for okay we'll talk about
chaplain movies because these are also
really really influential and when you
look at a movie like the gold rush and
then when you watch the Great Dictator
later you can actually see one's a
classic but then you can see such a
progression in his career it's really
amazing and it's not like the Great
Dictator was easy to make yeah that was
that was really hit a tough time making
cuz like America at that point but you
know it's funny those wasn't in the war
yet those nuts despise with the Stooges
came out before the great day huh huh I
know and it's like an America at that
time was like I don't know maybe we're
gonna stay out of this yeah yeah problem
yeah just yeah war one was brutal and
and and its pilot job was like no this
is what's going on I'm gonna help get
America into the war yeah and you
couldn't even say bad things about
hitler then like in the papers or stop
mm-hmm it was a weird time you look back
and you're like what no that couldn't
have had that can't be true which is why
right here when you hear stories of you
know whatever who will we might never
know about how you know the Pearl Harbor
all the top ranking officials were
pulled out of there like like oh yeah
yeah we r mu that was coming yeah and
then just kind of you know you if you go
and tour then you can hear the tour
guides give you a lot of the inside
stuff too like I when I went on I toward
Pearl Harbor they show the official
video but then you know they also the
tour guides kind of give you like the
unofficial stuff like you know when that
bombing occurred all the aircraft
carriers were gone because they knew
that would make a big difference in the
war if they sank so they were on
maneuvers and all this other things that
like well you know no one knows for sure
but here's some of the things that you
may not know yeah after they are like
needed the old rumor is he was like
dancing in the white house when it
happened cuz he was like now cuz we just
saw the movie about the Enigma code and
like did we know did ya written let us
know that the attack was coming and you
know we got everything out of the way
that we needed to win the war before the
back happened yeah and justified us to
start the war effort and especially when
you think of like radar well we thought
it was a flock of geese like really the
ring is that I'm sophisticated you
thought that was a flock of geese baby
giant flaw yeah Ben were like big oh
yeah they were getting stronger and they
all carried machine guns and torpedoes
and instead of squawking they'd miss
channeling and they would talk to each
other in Japanese oh yeah people didn't
know that their refer to the Emperor and
all this stuff no one said hey you know
what maybe we should have radar we can't
really tell anybody a difference between
anything um so let's talk about um
what's your favorite Chaplin movie let's
see you know it's so funny with Chaplin
I he's one of those guys that I watch
and admire more than life I hmm like I
always watch him and go wow that's great
what he did there and that's really
innovative but I don't remember really
laughing out loud at Chaplin more of an
appreciation yeah both laugh mmhmm yeah
because he was I mean you know he was a
craftsman the immigrant and the kid and
stuff like that he was again kind of
showing what was the part of what was
some of the struggles of the times in a
comedic way but it is true you do kind
of go oh wow you know look what emotion
he conveyed in that scene that again
looks like oh he's just being so yeah
Charlie Chaplin but it's like no there's
a lot of depth to that and and it you
know if you think about that now in this
era you know you can talk and say all
these things with the emotion and he
couldn't I mean he had such a limited
way to express the emotion and he did it
oh yeah in black and white films which
was amazing to me and I think he even
said to one of his actresses as a
direction he said um give a bad
performance
and I think that was cuz a great
performance back then was very
theatrical right and so making the
transition from silent to talkies yeah
well also wasn't like I think maybe he
was also bringing the stage cuz you're
of stage actors coming to this new
medium your vaudeville to in vaudeville
which was so big and so over the top and
you had to fill the whole theatre with
your physicality that it did seem
ridiculous and you also like we're
talking about you watch these movies as
products of the time look you look at
gold rush at 1925 finding gold yeah and
you look at like depression like that
was kind of it even played out in a
fantasy way we're like look we're all
poor we'd love to find gold and it has
again the product of the time you have
to realize what people were going
through when they were watching this
film and he was a train right right i
hope i had no money yeah we're and they
were being kicked out of their homes
yeah and he was like championing the
pork the little guy yeah there's one
movie I forget which one where he comes
over on a boat with a bunch of immigrant
I think it's the immigrant yeah 1917 Oh
like the immigrant that's like saying
what's that movie that has the Titanic
in it yeah movie most of Godzilla movie
about the big tall lizard that fights
smashes buildings well awesome man
that's our episode you guys that was a
lot of fun I love talking about this I
love it yeah and like we said seek out
these movies you won't be disappointed
just don't look at them through
contemporary eyes look at them as though
they wear products at the time and the
building blocks of modern comedy and you
will enjoy them so much more yeah and
then you know if anybody you're watching
these for the first time or or have any
recommendations again go to our message
board go to the Facebook fan page and
let us know you know there's many we
didn't get to recover
this page is 33 long yeah yeah we talked
about WC Fields Oh borrow and Hardy
there's a million WC Fields has again ty
so many kind of a little side room is
that you're just like wow that was
awesome meito do one just on the silent
comedies cuz we could just get into well
for sure yeah you know Buster Keaton and
now I thought I think it'd be great to
scratches so now we deals which what's
your amazing film so alright well
Gilbert thanks for being on the show
where can people find you on the
internet and see and listen your problem
since you brought it I hate to plug
myself but it since you mentioned it I
have a podcast Gilbert Gottfried's
amazing colossal podcast you could hear
it on Gilbert Gottfried calm and what
was it dad into itunes and sideshow
networked a TV uh it's a facebook is
Gilbert Gottfried's amazing colossal
podcast Facebook and my Twitter is at
real Gilbert and my twitter is a very
expensive hobby I found holes of it yeah
what are you spending money on exactly
platform yeah hey catch a long yeah I
think I'd like to hear it oh yeah
awesome well thanks for being on the
show and talking about this all right
guys you know like us on the facebook
fan page and again positive reviews on
itunes always help and definitely
support the store like we said twenty
dollars a year gets something we really
appreciate it helps pay for everything
oh and can I mention patreon here for my
podcast sure klk patreon yeah and become
a member and my podcast well you need to
pay for your Twitter account yes right
yes and and for God's sakes once again
let's tell you please see Ernest goes to
camp yeah it's true
my favorite is Ernest saves Christmas
yeah yeah that's where we disagree wait
yeah Santa's in the slammer come on guys
that was from the trailer all right guys
uh and of course where you are on comedy
film nerds is on at comedy film words on
twitter follow us you know free for free
I don't know what Gilbert said I deal
with ideas cuz I lost the job because my
job on Twitter ah Jesus mistake buying
every joke tio2 that one yes so now who
is the name of the first baseman yes oh
did you lose a job on facebook well on
my yes on Gilbert Gottfried's amazing
colossal podcast on facebook and Gilbert
Gottfried calm I've lost several
separable we're gonna really need level
later for this show yeah I just
remembered an Abbott and Costello Meet
Frankenstein it seems like he screws up
aligned at one point I starts to forget
because Costello goes mr. broadhurst and
they were cranking about so fast the
project now have type of it take alright
guys that's our show liking us on all
the social media is a thing you can do
for free that helps us those numbers
actually do help with sponsorship and I
just want to say Gilbert is great to see
you again Ivan to you any years oh yeah
I remember when I opened for Gilbert I
didn't feel I was like yeah you know my
early twenties I remember you asked me
the first thing you said to me is like
what appetizer should I get and I said
I'm not sure which one's better than he
went I'll just order all of them
hahaha that professional conversation
what happens in a comic of these
professional conversations a headliner
comes in throws his money around ya eyes
all the appetizers you know you think
it's all like Frank and Dino and Sammy
and Vegas potato skins and chicken
fingers shoes I'll just get all of them
mozzarella sticks I don't give a [ __ ]
all right guys well that's our show
thank you so much gilbere for coming out
my name is grandma what I'm Chris
Mancini as always remember haha shot
first